[Music]
how did you come to write this book what
really struck me was that too few books
were about my people where are our
stories where's our representation would
you give us the pleasure of reading an
excerpt yo Shir girl you be pregnant
again if I is Ray Ray is going to be a
real father this time
around thank
you
W monk your books are good but they're
not popular editors they want a black
book they have a black book I'm black
and it's my book you know what I
mean look at what they published look at
what they expect us to write I just want
to rub their noses
it I be standing outside in the night
dead beat dads rappers crack you said
you wanted black stuff that's black
right I see what you're
doing we sold your book no we believe Mr
Lee has written a bestseller it's a joke
the most lucrative joke you've ever told
now is stag a pseudonym yeah Mr Lee
can't use his real name is this based on
your actual
life yeah you think some ass
college boy can come up with that
no no no I
don't can I ask what you were in for was
a murder you said that not me they ran
300,000 copies ear books change people's
lives they're offering $4 million for
moving rights yes the Dumber I behave
the Richer I
get this has gone too far stag Arley is
still on the run for authorities you
haven't done anything it's not like they
can arrest
you wish I could go back to not selling
books is it bad to cater to people's
taste people want to love you Monk you
should let them love all of you there's
already so much Buzz because of the
movie deal Michael B Jordan is circling
we want to put him on the cover in one
of those um scarves I guess you would
call them tied around his head a doag
doag that's it doag in a tank top with
the muscles showing something called the
fire
[Music]
department we're thinking we can get it
out in time for gun
he